y avanzar en la cooperación árabe
israelí y sobre todo en seguridad es la
principal meta del presidente
estadounidense joe biden en su viaje a
medio oriente en su primera visita a la
región como mandatario baiden estará
miércoles y jueves en israel el viernes
a visitar jerusalén este y cisjordania y
partirá hacia arabia saudita para cerrar
el sábado su gira en una cumbre con
naciones del golfo con irán como amenaza
común el líder norteamericano buscará
acercar a israel y arabia saudita una
intención que simbólicamente se va a ver
reflejada en el vuelo directo que los
llevará de tel aviv ayer a por primera
vez aunque no se espera una
normalización de relaciones como si
ocurrió entre israel y otras naciones a
veces bajo los llamados acuerdos de
abraham si se esperan gestos como que
arabia saudita abra su espacio aéreo a
puertos israelíes también podría
asentarse la idea de colaboración
militar en concreto para coordinar
sistemas de defensa antimisiles
precisamente el gobierno israelí
exhibirá baile en sus herramientas de
defensa con énfasis en un nuevo láser
antimisiles para el que busca obtener
fondos estadounidenses lejos de tratarlo
como estado varias como prometió by ten
se acercará a arabia saudita para según
sus palabras reorientar la histórica
alianza entre sus países la necesidad de
entre otras cosas de negociar sobre los
precios del petróleo dejaron en segundo
plano problemáticas como las violaciones
a los derechos humanos o el asesinato
del periodista llamado hawks y también
relegado quedaría el conflicto
israelí-palestino aunque se espera que
bailen anunció un mayor apoyo para los
hospitales palestinos son de jerusalén
este y otras medidas de alivio mientras
más ambiciosas como la reapertura del
consulado de estadounidense para asuntos
palestinos prometen quedar en deuda
aumentando el escepticismo de los
palestinos hacia washington al que ven
como un garante de la ocupación israelí